mmm so oh my voice is failing me welcome
to this video yeah should have drank
something before i started the video
yeah welcome this is a 15-minute game
that had just started here on the eyes
you seem and I must say I'm happily out
writing my opponent super roll 2000 yeah
sloth defense incredibly popular opening
yeah he's playing the triangle I like to
play Queen c2 against this always my
favorite line against us it's a fairly
flexible way to play covering see phone
and then still keep my options open for
this an active Bishop development yeah
he went for a very standard setup Bishop
e7 not bd7 this is not the most
promising way to play but it's certainly
yea rather reliable a bit passive though
sorry about that yeah I'm back from
Hamburg where I'm produced some content
for chest to any form the website that
is doing many broadcasts nowadays and
Hamburg was some yeah I mean that's not
really at the coast but it felt rather
yeah always had this kind of windy
quality no it felt feels like I'm got a
slight cold okay black went for d takes
and b5 this is a valid way to play
however he took on c4 without even
haven't waited for me to move my Bishop
to d3 OE to which I probably would have
done so this is some yeah something that
I cannot be too upset about I wonder how
to continue my my dream scenario here
obviously is that I want to yeah I'd
like to make sure that yes not even that
he is not even able to UM to play c5
yeah 90 45 looks very tempting let's do
that and not think too much the
likelihood is very high that I going to
play it anyway so let's just do it okay
our way maybe it can go be4 night a 45
here hmm should have thought about that
a bit more now I think him he also
should do that here be 49 a 45 that is
something that this opportunity should
not he does he does he 5v5 and that's it
how I see not losing material now
hmm Joe that's a piece right i mean ii 7
has unprotected and 95 I take d5 with
tempo and then check yourself now he had
to play before definitely I think maybe
my you for move wasn't even even so well
timed this is just a piece
black resigned yeah let's look at this I
think he formed maybe he wasn't even so
great iam now that I'm but it is a [ __ ]
Ted too quickly before it's good now he
should play that I know that this is not
yeah a really full game at this quick
game but it is interesting because of
this single moment yeah Maya for move
was premature here before I go night FYE
go see five and now we see that my queen
is badly placed thereon see toward this
particular moment it's a bit awkward now
I mean if I take maybe but you can even
go here
yeah that this is perfectly good for
black I'm now tied to this annoyed let's
say here cheeks it something like that
and black isn't perfectly good shape he
is also he's got this his weakness to
look at now that was good I should not
should not play you for him but what is
it that I should do I mean one move that
I can place a three well maybe I mean
also it comes into consideration to just
remove the Queen from the sea fowl
definitely or this one is also quite
interesting maybe this move looks looks
okay if he goes before now and may be
able to go here now something like let's
say here we imagine this this looks I he
second place if I hmm it's not doing any
good hmm a check here
and black us again okay so night if I'd
is not good ah maybe I should really
just go to e2 because the queen is such
that's not a good spot here maybe create
you again he goes here and again he gets
that and so when something is wrong here
what is wrong here maybe a three then
flicking this and now that might be
might be useful so let's say a six
preparing c5 and then 95 maybe this sir
maybe this is good for small edge I can
also think about before but if five
rupee one may be here
yeah this this this is an interesting
line strategic exchange sacrifice giving
black hideous and now not that it night
here to here or to you for interesting
interesting stuff yeah that kind of
opening always leads to interesting play
later on but if for was definitely a
mistake and this he just just loses the
game but it was still interesting here
because of this particular moment if
always mistimed really is this is this
is a bit awkward I should play 3m if he
goes here at with an idea let's think
about this one tour before and probably
still that
they have is probably good for small
advantage I should have a small
advantage I really should I mean he
basically what here the sword setup
isn't that brilliant anyway and here
took here in one move which sometimes
black wins the temple with with a move
let's say please rookie eight or
something the likelihood is it's pretty
big that I play the bishop out and then
he has gained a move not a very
important one body has gained to move so
I should have some slight advantage
Marin tiara castling cannot be bad now
but a three is much better than NC 5
yeah it was a short game but still have
been interesting because of this
particular moment yeah I hope you
enjoyed it it is a not a real record
game more like a blitz game in disguise
but what can you do thanks for watching